I would tell kids who want to make  movies to make movies when I was a kid  the only way I can make movies was  borrow money from my father and borrow  his eight millimeter movie camera and  borrow the money because film was  expensive the film and the developing of  the film was expensive then today you  can take your telephone your your F your  cell phone you can make a movie on that  if it's a really cool movie and it's  funny and it's dramatic or whatever you  can post it on YouTube so it's a lot  easier for kids today to get started and  follow their passion and pursue their  hearts you know desire to be a filmmaker  because the tools that were less  available to my generation growing up  are completely available to yours so  there's no reason why you can't express  who you are through video